In this video we're going to show you how you can integrate BoopSuite Enterprise Edition with Slack.
Now before we start, it's important to point out that the person doing this integration needs to be the workspace owner for the workspace where the integration is going to happen.
If you want, then you won't have the required permissions to go ahead with this.
So the first thing we're going to do is we're going to sign in to the Slack workspace where we want the integration as that workspace owner.
For the purposes of this demo, I've already done that.
Next, we need to create a channel for the notifications to be sent to.
If you've already done that, then you can skip this next step.
To do that, we're going to click Add Channels, create a new channel, and then give that channel a name.
I'm just going to call it Enterprise Notifications.
For the purposes of the demo, I'll make it public, and then I'll skip this step.
Once we have the channel created, the next thing we need to do is create an application within the Slack administration page,
and that's what Boop will communicate with in order to send the notifications to your Slack channel.
To do that, you'll need to navigate to api.slack.com forward slash apps.
Once you're on this page, you can create an app from scratch, and then give that application a name.
I'm just going to name that something like Enterprise Notifications Bot.
As the interface says, you can change this later.
This name is the name that will show in Slack when it sends a notification, but like I say, you can change this later.
Then I'm going to pick the workspace which I want to integrate the bot with, and then I'll click Create App.
Once the app has been created, we'll need to give it some certain permissions so that it can actually send the notifications to the Slack channel.
To do that, we're going to go to Features, OAuth and Permissions, and under Scopes Bot Token Scopes, we're going to add a few OAuth scopes.
Those scopes are channels read, groups read, IM read, MPIM read, chat write, and users read.
These are the six permissions that you'll need to grant this application so that it can actually do its job.
You can see a description for what the permissions are.
They aren't anything nasty. They don't do anything that you wouldn't expect them to.
But unfortunately, if you aren't happy with the permissions that you need to grant, then you won't be able to carry out this integration.
Once you've assigned the permissions, the next thing that you can do is customize how the messages will show within the Slack interface.
To do that, you can scroll back up to the top and click Basic Information, and once that page is loaded, scroll down to the bottom to this Display Information section.
Here, you can set the name of the app, which is how it will show in Slack when it sends a notification.
You can add a description, either a short or a long one.
You can set a color for the messages to come through as, and you can also add an app icon, which is how also the icon for the user which sends the notifications will be displayed.
For the purposes of the demo, I won't go into the role of this.
But once you've done that, the next thing that you need to do is install the application into your workspace in Slack.
The way that you do that is on this page, you just scroll back up to the top and you click Install to Workspace.
You'll be prompted to allow some certain permissions.
These permissions are just the permissions which you granted in the previous steps, those OAuth scopes that I was talking about before.
You don't need to worry about anything on this page, you can just click Allow.
Once you've allowed those permissions, the next thing you'll need to do is go back to your Slack workspace.
Within the channel where you want the notifications to be sent, you can click the drop down button next to the name,
and then click Integrations, and then Add an App.
And you should be able to see the name of the bot, or the name of the application which you just created through the administration page.
You then need to add that to your channel, and you know that you've done that correctly if you see a message saying that the name of the application has joined your channel.
Once you've done this, you know that you've integrated the bot to the channel, and the next thing that you need to do is integrate Enterprise with Slack.
To do that, you need to go to your Enterprise console, click the cog icon, and then Integrations.
You then need to scroll down to the bottom, and click Configure under Slack, and then enter a Slack OAuth token.
To get that token, you'll need to go back to that administration page we were on before, and under the application which we just made,
if you go back down to OAuth and permissions, you'll then need to copy the bot user OAuth token that it generates for you.
Once you've done that, if you paste that token into the Enterprise console, and then click Connect, Enterprise will connect to Slack for you.
And once you're on this page, you know that the integration has worked correctly.
The next thing you'll need to do is tell Enterprise which channels it can send messages to.
If you have multiple different sites, and you want your notifications of different sites to be sent to specific channels,
you'll need to enable all of the channels where you want the messages to be sent to.
I only created the one channel, so I'm going to enable that.
Once we've done that, we then need to set the site so that any notifications relating to ScanProgress for it get sent to those Slack channels.
To do that, navigate to the site within the Enterprise console.
Under Details, click Edit, and then scroll down to the bottom.
In the Notifications section, under Send Scan Notifications to Slack, click the name of the channel where you want the notifications to be sent to,
and click Save.
At this point, the integration is complete, but for the purposes of the demo, I'll show you what that looks like during the scan.
So I'll kick off the scan now, and we'll be able to see the messages that are showing Slack as the scan progresses.
So now the scan is completed, we can look at the Slack interface to see what messages have been sent.
And you can see that we've received messages for when the scan started, for when the scan completed, and under the reply for when the scan completed,
you'll see a summary report, which mentions the number of issues found, some statistics about the scan, and a direct link to that scan within the Enterprise console.
And that is how you integrate Slack with Burp Suite Enterprise.
And that is how you integrate the scan, and the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the scan for the